we were given two dice to roll one is
black with six sides the other is will
write white with four sides so a four
sided die is kind of a pyramid looking
thing it has exactly four sides so for a
given role would be a pyramid with a
triangular base for a given roll what is
the probability that the dice add up to
10 if it helps you might may select the
matching outcomes below your selections
aren't checked with your answer so this
might look a little bit strange at first
you're like what is this triangle this
triangle is the face of the of the
four-sided die that is face that is
facing you so this is the role of the
four-sided die and so this is a roll of
one and one so those clearly are not
adding up to ten so let's think about
all the ones that add up to ten so this
adds up to two this adds up to three
this adds up to four this adds up to
five let's see what actually adds up to
ten so if we go all the way so clearly
if we get a 4 and a 6 that's going to
add up to 10 and are there any other
possibilities that add up to 10 well the
highest possible roll I can get on the
four-sided die is a 4 so that's the my
best scenario out of that's the highest
possible roll and even if I get that I
still need the highest possible role on
the six-sided die so this is the only
scenario that adds up to 10 you could
look at all any of these other ones
they'll add up to something less than 10
so there's one possibility that
satisfies our constraints that dies at
the dice add up to 10 and how many total
equally likely possibilities were there
let's see this grid shows all the
equally likely possibilities this is 1 2
3 4 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 they're 24 equally
likely possibilities and that comes from
you have 6 you have 6 possibilities from
the six-sided die times 4 possibilities
from the four-sided I gives you 24
equally likely possibilities only one
matches or only one satisfies the
constraints the constraint that the dice
add up to 10 let's do a few more of
these so you're given two six-sided dice
to roll for given roll what is the
probability that the dice add to 6 so
here we have the tops of both of my dice
and now what are all the scenarios where
the dice add up to six so I have to get
in order to add up well let's think
about this if I have a 1 and a 5 that's
going to add up to 6 in this entire
column that's the only way that I add up
to 6
right over here let's see if I have a 2
on the black die then I'm going to need
a 4 on the white die to add up to 6 but
with 3 on the black dime going to use a
3 on the white die to add up to 6
before on the black die I'm going to
need a 2 on the white die if I have a 5
on the Black Diamond we need a one on
the white die and then if I have a 6 on
the black that it's actually impossible
that the sum will be exactly 6 so
there's no zero on the white die so none
of these meet the constraint so here I
have 1 2 3 4 5 possibilities where my
dice add up to 6
so I have 5 possibilities out of a total
of 36 equally likely ones this is a 6 by
6 grid and it comes from 6 possibilities
for one die times 6 possibilities for
the other die so 5 possibilities satisfy
my constraint out of a total of 36 let's
do one more this is actually a lot of
fun you're given two six-sided right row
you are given two six-sided dice to roll
for a given role what is the probability
at least one die is a six at least one
dies a 6 so let's see so we just have to
look for all of the all of the
situations where at least one of the
dice is a 6 so that one that one every
time I see is 6 I should just click on
that that one that one and then
obviously all of these scenarios right
over here so these are all the scenarios
where at least one of the diocese of 6
here of course is where both of the dice
are 6 so how many scenarios are there 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 so there are 11
possibilities out of a total of 36
equally likely ones remember 6 times 6
or 36 equally likely outcomes so let's
check our answer and we got it right